chris sims has the baltimore ravens with
their two first-round picks number 31
courtesy of the kids city chiefs taking
at 27
edge rusher azizojalari of georgia and
then alex leatherwood tackle from
alabama at 31 you'll find out about 15
minutes where the pft mock oh
it's going oh johnny mock draft is here
today
there could be there could be some
overlap between yours and ours we'll
find out in about 15 minutes before then
let's find out what coach john harbaugh
had to say on the rich eisens show about
lamar jackson's future with the team
here's coach harbaugh
i did walk across the hall right now and
ask eric but i'm quite sure that
can i can i make that guarantee right
now on your show yes just we'll fill the
vacuum up right now
his fifth year option will be picked up
okay guarantee it
that was that's as good as the jim
harbaugh guarantee in 1986
another time boat shoot him out i'm sure
you know back in the day so there's
nothing to the fact that this hasn't
happened to this point in time nothing
there's nothing to the fact no because
you know because you know they're
they're everybody is waiting for the
time
where a team
will utilize the fact that a quarterback
being on the first iteration of a
contract allowing you to have more
salary cap space
and just going ahead despite how
talented the quarterback that you have
drafted before and how successful he may
be
to just give that a whirl uh in team
building and championship building and
obviously you and the ravens are such at
the forefront of analytics in this world
and people are looking at you as
thinking maybe you might actually be the
first team to try something like that
but that is not going to happen with
lamar no no his fifth fifth year he's
gonna get picked up
he's definitely gonna be our quarterback
so
um that's that's the plan absolutely
okay there's a donut hole there that was
completely ignored what
well you can pick up the fifth year
option and then let him go after that
yeah i know you you you don't you don't
it's not it's not four years or none
after that it you can pick up the uh
picking up the option is not the same as
giving him an extension now if you
really wanted to make news yesterday
john harbaugh on the rich eisenhower
elsewhere what you should have said was
we signed him to an extension that's the
real question here picking up the fifth
year option is a no-brainer you're not
going to let him go after four years
he's not mitch trubisky he was the
freaking mvp
you're keeping him for five years don't
i and i'm look i'm not saying
that that this means that the ravens are
considering drafting a quarterback this
year or next year and and doing the
bucky brooks suggested
scenario of treating it like college
football and graduating your quarterback
and replacing him with another one i'm
fascinated by the prospect of that
i just don't think you do it with lamar
jackson and you definitely don't do it
by not picking up his fifth year option
of course you're picking up his fifth
year option of course you are the
question is how much does he want beyond
year five
are you willing to break the bank like
you did for joe flacco and that didn't
really work out for the ravens all that
well when they broke the bank twice for
flacco
and uh and and is there is there given
lamar jackson's playing style
a reason to replace him with another
quarterback who can do the same things
he does and just keep going every four
or five years and another quarterback
another quarterback another quarterback
but just the fact that they're picking
up the fifth year option doesn't it
doesn't pull the plug on that debate you
excite him to a long-term contract
that's what pulls the plug on the debate
yeah that'll that'll end the discussion
i i think you know john was probably
trying to say that like he's going to be
our quarterback at the very end i mean
at least that's what i kind of took at
that is like that's where it's going you
know don't expect any like crazy thing
now hey bucky books bucky brooks the
conversation he brought up like about
you know the your how you explained it
hey it's interesting it's a great point
i think there's something to that to a
degree now the other thing too here is
you know again with this offense
specifically listen lamar jackson's
special no you know as good as justin
fields is at running the ball and trey
lance or running the ball let me just
make this clear it ain't like lamar
jackson coming out all right lamar
jackson's running was on a whole other
level a whole nother level i think
people have forgot that here four or
five years down the road now everybody
just thinks he'll be like lamar jackson
oh you mean like one of the greatest
runners we've ever seen in the open
field in history wow we can just pin
that to these guys now no so that's
that's one thing to take into account
here bucky brooks's thing though is real
i think if you get a situation where the
quarterback
hasn't definitely solidified himself as
a big-time player aka going back to what
you always said with jared goff like
that would be the center yeah the team
was good but come on any human watching
can really see he's not that special
let's make the move and do it this one's
different to me to where
you know he's the leader of the football
team he's the one of the best players in
the league the team is built around him
and
i think this is one you do stick in
there with is what i'm saying this is
not the one where you go let's abandon
ship and get another quarterback and try
to do it again with somebody else
i guess is what i'm trying to say long
story short there i'll give you one that
better fits right than lamar jackson
because i agree with you i like the idea
from bucky brooks yeah and we've been
waiting for a team to have the
intestinal fortitude to say
we're not paying just because you're on
the pass side of the pass fail line
we're not paying you yeah i think baker
mayfield is the one that better fits
into that box
it i mean this will be a big year
you're i mean you're right we'll see i
mean again now
last year was pretty damn good so yes he
needs to back that up with another year
for us to go okay
yep it's going all in the right
direction we're good we'll pay you money
blah blah blah but yeah if it's
real average you know and they find ways
to win games despite him and all those
type of things i hear you mike that
could be part of the conversation
there's no doubt about that but this is
this is a special scenario and you know
unlike joe flacco the team was built
around the defense then and i know they
have a really good defense now but the
the the the
the culture of the team and everything
they stand for is about lamar and the
running game and i think that's why they
will reward him ultimately here some
sometime in the near future
but but we can't forget their experience
with joe flacco i know that may cause
them to avoid and and the sooner they
move the better putting themselves in a
spot where they're over a barrel like
they were in early 2013 after flacco bet
on himself
won the super bowl mvp award they made
him the highest paid player in football
in early 2013 to even avoid the
possibility of the non-exclusive
franchise tag and someone offering two
first-round picks because there were a
couple of teams thinking about that as
crazy as it sounds now and then three
years later because the cap charges they
had to make him the highest paid player
in the nfl again to get out of the cap
mess they created the first time around
i don't think they want to do that again
yeah and yeah and that's going to be the
challenge because the march accident
doesn't have a traditional agent it's
going to be a very delicate difficult
negotiation between lamar jackson
whoever's advising him and the ravens
directly to get the right number for
lamar jackson and i i think they should
keep him but i think that bucky brooks
suggestion
that in the right spot with the right
team just because the quarterback is
panned out doesn't mean you pay him
maybe you draft another one and keep the
trip rolling with so many good young
quarterbacks coming out every year as
long as you don't pick a lemon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports